SOUTHERN CHARM IT WAS SPECULATED
THAT LACROIX WAS MESSAGING WITH
AROD ON INSTAGRAM.
WILL: THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IS
SET TO RECEIVE A WINDFALL OF
MORE THAN $1.3 BILLION IN
BAILOUT MONEY AND LIBERAL MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IS ECSTATIC TO
SPEND IT ON HIS LEFT-WING
AGENDA.
>> NOW WITH THIS MONEY WE CAN
PUT THAT MONEY BACK INTO THE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT WHICH WE CAN PAY
OFF THE CREDIT CARD, DELIVER
LIFE-SAVING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, AND RESPONSES WE
REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY, MONEY
TO IMPROVE OUR PENSIONS, LOWER
PEOPLE’S HEALTHCARE COSTS,
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
PETE: BUSINESSES THAT WERE
TRAMPLED BY HIS LOCKDOWNS, THE
OWNER/FISH RESTAURANT AND OWNER
OF PINEAPPLE HILL SALOON ANGELA
MARSDEN, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I WILL START WITH YOU.
IT TOUCHED EVERYONE BECAUSE IT
WAS A BLATANT EXAMPLE OF
HYPOCRISY BETWEEN THE MOVIE SET
AND YOUR RESTAURANTS.
ERIC GARCETTI SAID HE IS FLUSH
WITH CASH NOW.
WHAT SHOULD HE DO WITH IT?
>> THE CLIP YOU JUST PLAYED, NOT
ONCE DID HE SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
GETTING THE MONEY BACK TO THE
PEOPLE, HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES, HELPING THE
UNEMPLOYED, LOS ANGELES IS THE
NUMBER ONE CITY IN THE UNITED
STATES, WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
MAYOR WHO BASICALLY KEEPS THE
MONEY FOR HIMSELF AND DOESN’T
SPEND IT ON THE PEOPLE.
LA NEEDS THAT MONEY FOR SURE
BECAUSE OF HIS TOTAL
MISMANAGEMENT AND PAID TO PLAY
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON.
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE WITHIN OUR
CITY THAT HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
PAID TO PLAY THE WORK UNDER HIM.
THE MONEY NEVER GOES WHERE IT IS
SUPPOSED TO GO.
I WISH THE MONEY WAS GIVEN TO
HIM WITH STRINGS ALLOCATING IT
TOWARDS THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
NEED IT LIKE OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES, OUR HOMELESS.
HE PUT $430 MILLION TO THE
HOMELESS LAST YEAR AND IT WENT
UP ALMOST 16%.
THE MONEY UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT
GOING TO GO TOWARD HELPING
STABILIZE THE BACKYARD OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS,
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF LOS
ANGELES, HE DIDN’T MENTION ANY
OF THAT ON WHERE THE MONEY IS
SPENT, PUT IT IN THE BANK.
WE HAVE THE LARGEST HOMELESS
CRISIS GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND
HE’S TALKING ABOUT PUTTING MONEY
IN SAVINGS.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT PLANET THIS
GUY LIVES ON.
PETE: THE HOMELESS PROBLEM IS
LIKE SOMETHING I HAVE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT ANY OF THIS
MONEY WILL GO TO THE PEOPLE HE
LOCKED DOWN FOR YEAR?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
HE’S REWARDING HIMSELF OR FAILED
POLICIES.
HE DID AN AWFUL JOB AND NOW WILL
BE PAID BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
IT.
THERE’S 10,000 RESTAURANTS IN
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
YOU COULD GIVE EVERY SINGLE
RESTAURANT 50,$000 AND STILL
HAVE ROUGHLY $1 BILLION LEFT
OVER HE COULD DOLE OUT TO BREAK
THE CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS,
PERHAPS HELP OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES.
WHAT HE’S DOING IS USING THE
MONEY TO FIX PROBLEMS THAT
PROBABLY EXISTED PRIOR TO
CORONAVIRUS.
IMAGINE IF I TRIED TO GIVE PPP
MONEY FOR BUSINESSES THAT I
SHUTDOWN THAT WERE
UNDERPERFORMING, THEY WERE
ALREADY SHUTDOWN, THAT IS WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
>> COVID RELIEF MONEY TO FIX
THINGS BASED ON FAILED LIBERAL
POLICIES THAT ARE STILL THERE,
NOT HELPING THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE